When the sun rose on that fateful day, Jerry
Marks had been one of the lucky ones.
He worked in a mine, deep underground, at
the edge of a small town in the rural United
States.
Which meant he didn’t see what happened
when day broke, when the light of the sun
ravaged the Earth.
The first Jerry heard about it was when his
son Kyle came racing into the mine, frantically
tapping his dad’s shoulder to get his attention.
He’d run all the way from their tiny homestead
under a fireproof blanket, thick and long
enough to block the sunlight from touching
any part of Kyle’s skin.
His older sister, Jerry’s daughter Carly,
hadn’t been so lucky.
Caught by the light, her body had turned the
consistency of warm candle wax, melting into
a form that barely resembled human anymore.
Jerry had been one of a handful of others
working late in the mine that day.
A few thought that young Kyle had made the
whole story up, and ventured up to the surface
– and into the light – only to meet the
same, twisted fate.
The light morphed their bodies into monstrosities,
anyone in the small, rural community becoming
an amorphous mass of human flesh.
Eventually, those that stayed behind in the
mine heard the voices of their loved ones,
their wives, husbands, children, all calling
out to them from outside.
They promised that nothing was wrong, that
it was a lovely, sunny day outside, and the
mine workers should clock out to come and
enjoy it.
More of them left, reassured by hearing their
families that all was well.
And once more, none of them were seen again.
Only Jerry and Kyle were left, and it stayed
that way for several months.
The father and son had to adapt to life underground,
only leaving the mine to forage for food – and
only while wearing thick, dirty mining overalls,
making sure not a single millimeter of skin
was on display.
If the sunlight touched them, they’d never
make it back alive.
Venturing out of the mine in his overalls,
Jerry had seen the shuffling, melted mass
that had once been the townsfolk.
He did his best to avoid it as he went house
to house, making sure it never saw him while
he raided cupboards and refrigerators.
But he could see it, and among the blobs of
bodies blended together, he saw something
that resembled his daughter.
It turned his stomach, not just knowing but
actually witnessing what had happened to her.
And it was made all the worse on the days
that Carly called out to him and Kyle, while
they hid in the mine.
It was clearly her voice, but there was something
wrong about it; perhaps knowing that she was
a part of the melted monstrosity made it easier
to resist her trying to coax them out into
the light.
It had been almost an entire year of life
spent mostly underground when Jerry and Kyle
encountered their first actual human beings
since all the other workers had left the mine.
The pair that arrived were strange, wearing
protective suits that covered them both head
to toe.
Just like Jerry and Kyle had quickly realised,
these two were aware that not even the tiniest
hint of the sun’s unforgiving light could
be allowed to reach them.
The two approached Jerry and Kyle seemingly
coming in peace, although the father and son
remained cautious of the newcomers.
Making sure they were deep enough in the mine
to avoid the sunlight at the stony entrance,
the pair of them revealed their faces, confirming
they were still fully human, before introducing
themselves as Researcher Worth and Sergeant
Booker of the SCP Foundation.
Sitting down with Jerry, Worth explained to
him what had really happened; he had been
working for an organization that contained
and studied anomalous creatures and phenomena,
the Foundation.
Booker had been a member of a special armed
unit within the same establishment, or a Mobile
Task Force.
But now the SCP Foundation itself had fallen,
with a number of its own personnel turned
into more of the amorphous fleshy creatures
in the sunlight.
“We spent a lot of years keeping all this
from the public,” Worth admitted, sounding
guilty but implying the choice was out of
his hands.
“But I don’t suppose there’s any point
in secrets anymore.
It’s the sun, you see, Mr Marks-”
“You can call me Jerry,” he interrupted.
“Sorry, Jerry,” Worth corrected himself.
“But something happened to the sun.
It changed, decimated the entire planet in
barely any time at all.
I mean all those people, millions… billions
all at once.
Dear god.”
Worth took a moment as the existential dread
of it all once again caught up with him.
“It turned out the biggest anomaly was right
above us,” Booker continued for him; she
sounded a lot more stoic, even a little coldly
detached from it all.
“SCP-001, that’s what the Foundation called
it.”
“Is there a way to reverse it?
Or cure the people that the sunlight…
changes?”
Jerry asked, thinking of Carly.
“You mean SCP-001-A?
No, I’m sorry, Jerry, there’s nothing
we can do,” the researcher said, failing
to sound as recomposed as he pretended to
be.
“Your daughter is gone, but at least you
still have your-”
Worth paused, looking around the mine.
Even in the low light, there was no sign of
Kyle.
Jerry turned to scan the area; to his horror,
his son seemed to have vanished while they
were talking.
Instantly, panic caused him to think that
Kyle had wandered out of the mine and into
the sunlight, turning into part of what Worth
had called SCP-001-A. But the boy would’ve
had to walk past Jerry to start heading that
direction, plus the father knew his son was
far too scared to go outside after seeing
what the sun had done to Carly.
Booker had a tactical bag filled with equipment,
flashlights, spare batteries, even flares
for when the power in those ran out.
And both working and living in the mine so
long, Jerry had maps, knew certain routes
through the deep network of tunnels almost
by heart.
Between them, the three had enough to mount
a search for the missing Kyle.
Keeping together, they traversed away from
the first of several larger chambers, down
into the dark depths of the mine.
“Kyle!” his father yelled, his voice echoing
through the tunnel.
“Kyle, buddy, it’s dad!
You there?”
Walking behind him, Researcher Worth and Sergeant
Booker parroted the calls, assuring the missing
boy that they didn’t mean him or Jerry any
harm.
As the trio walked deeper and deeper, they
began to venture into a portion of the mine
that had hardly been used by the workers.
It was darker than the areas further up; while
those had rows of electric lamps powered by
long cables attached to generators, down here
the only light came from the flashlights the
group carried.
“Kyle, come on out!”
Jerry called out for his son again.
“This isn’t the time to split up, we need
to stick together!
Come on son, I’m really worried here!”
Once again, there was no answer.
Just then, Jerry caught sight of Booker and
Worth out of the corner of his eye.
Both of them knew a lot about SCP-001, and
the mine worker couldn’t help the suspicion
that added to his perception of them.
After all, Kyle had never run off before now,
and Jerry couldn’t help but think, while
his attention had been turned, that the pair
of Foundation personnel had taken his son.
“Dad?” a voice suddenly called out.
Jerry’s head spun on a swivel at the sound
of Kyle calling for him.
“Dad, where are you?”
it echoed through the tunnel again.
“That’s him!”
Jerry exclaimed to the other two.
“Which way did that come from?”
“Straight ahead, it sounds like,” Booker
replied.
“Hold on,” Worth interjected.
“I think you two should look at this.”
The beam from his flashlight was pointed at
the rocky floor of the tunnel.
Something was gleaming, wet against the stone:
a large smear of red, like something had been
dragged in the direction Kyle’s voice was
coming from.
“Oh god, he could be hurt!”
Jerry said urgently.
“Hurt might not be the right word, I’m
afraid, Jerry,” the researcher said solemnly.
“There’s a lot of blood here.
Too much.”
“All the more reason to go further and find
where he’s calling from,” the father retorted
angrily.
“That’s if it is actually the kid calling
us,” Booker replied, her and Worth exchanging
a worried glance at each other.
“You two know something, don’t you?”
Jerry demanded.
“Does that… the thing from outside, does
it have my son too?”
“Dad?” another voice called.
Jerry froze, his blood as cold as the mine
tunnel he was still stood in.
He hadn’t heard that voice in almost a year,
but recognised it immediately: it was Carly,
his daughter.
It seemed impossible, he knew she had been
merged into part of SCP-001-A when day broke,
but now she was somehow calling out to Jerry.
Her voice sounded clearer, like it had used
to before she changed.
And she wasn’t trying to lure her father
out into the sunlight either.
For a moment, it seemed to Jerry like his
daughter had somehow come back.
“Dad, we’re both over here!”
Carly’s voice called again.
“We need your help, Kyle’s stuck!”
“Who is that?”
Booker whispered.
“T-that’s Carly,” Jerry sniffed, holding
back tears.
“You said your daughter became a part of
SCP-001-A,” Worth pointed out.
“Maybe she got better?”
the father asked hopefully.
“I hate to say it, but that’s definitely
not her,” Sergeant Booker replied.
“We should turn back now, if there’s an
anomaly in these tunnels… that’s not gonna
be pretty for any of us,” she added, turning
to Worth.
“What?”
Jerry yelled.
“What do you mean by that?”
“Look buddy, those aren’t your children,”
the MTF agent said bluntly.
“It sounds like SCP-001-A got them.”
“No, no, the voices are too clear,” Worth
replied.
“I think there’s something else here.”
Before Jerry could explode with anger at how
uninterested both Foundation personnel seemed
at the fate of his children, another sound
was heard.
Footsteps, something shuffling closer, padding
its feet on the stone.
There was a low growl that filled the tunnel,
as whatever it was came closer still.
“Dad?” the voice of Carly repeated, sounding
only a few feet away now.
“Where are you, Dad?”
Kyle’s voice immediately followed it.
Behind came the sound of Booker striking a
flare.
As it erupted into a plume of light and heat,
she threw it down the tunnel: and there they
were.
Not Jerry’s children, but instead a pair
of nightmarish creatures.
They backed away from the flare slightly,
but the light still illuminated their blood-red
forms, walking on all fours like wolves.
The creature’s elongated heads were missing
any eyes, just jaws filled with rows of sharp,
red fangs.
“Daaaad,” came Kyle’s voice again…
emanating from one of the monsters.
It was mimicking Jerry’s son, both his kids.
Even having seen SCP-001-A at a distance,
the father could barely believe his eyes.
“939s!”
Booker yelled the second her flare illuminated
them.
“Run!”
She pulled a sidearm and opened fire, the
bang of each shot ringing loudly through the
tunnel.
The pair of SCP-939s pounced at her while
Jerry and Worth turned to run back the way
they had come.
As the creatures attacked, the echoes of gunfire
were replaced with blood-curdling screams.
“What the hell are those things?”
Jerry yelled in a panic.
“SCP-939!”
Researcher Worth panted.
“Too much to explain, they’re pack hunters
and they’re vicious.”
“What about Kyle and Carly?
I heard their voices!”
“That’s what those monsters do, they mimic
human speech to draw us out.
We’re their prey!
There’s no telling how long they’ve been
down here, they might have retreated to the
mine to avoid the sun on the surface!”
Worth yelled.
The sound of the SCP-939s getting closer were
catching up, right on Jerry’s and Worth’s
heels.
“What would they come down here for?”
the mine worker huffed, slightly ahead of
the researcher given his slightly stronger
physique.
“To escape the sunlight!”
Worth replied, “SCP-939’s hate bright
li-AAAAAHHHH!”
His sentence was overtaken by a scream as
one of the bloody red creatures caught Worth
by the ankle, knocking him down and pulling
him back to be devoured.
Jerry didn’t look back, just kept running
back through the tunnel.
The sounds of SCP-939 calling after him in
Kyle and Carly’s voices making it even harder
to not stop and turn, even just for a second.
But her reminded himself that if he stopped
running, then he couldn’t lure the creatures
of the mine and into the sunlight…
It wasn’t how he’d ever wanted to go out,
but maybe that way Jerry would see his kids
again.
Now go check out “SCP-001 CAN SCP-049 FINALLY
CURE WHEN DAY BREAKS?”
and “SCP-001 WHEN DAY BREAKS SCP-682”
for more horrifying When Day Breaks scenarios!